située à 27 km de vesoul et avant de
baume les dames
voici rougemont petite commune de 1250
habitants qui offre toutes les
commodités d'une grande
ici on peut faire l'ensemble de ses
courses et scolariser ses enfants
jusqu'au collège se tiendra si des gens
parce que ya aussi un tabac il ya là
donc alors là la boulangerie est fidèle
et super u et ceux qui accueillent c'est
simple tous les commerces qui paieraient
kit ailleurs prospère à rocheman côté
santé on a bien frôlé le désert médical
il ya six ans mais aujourd'hui ce n'est
plus qu'un mauvais souvenir
une maison médicale a ouvert ses portes
trois généralistes y exercent
bientôt un quatrième ainsi qu'un
dentiste deux infirmières et à tour de
rôle une sage-femme et un psychologue
david ghost rider participent aussi à ce
dynamisme sa pharmacie était devenu trop
petit alors il a fait le pari de
s'agrandir et de s'installer à quelques
mètres seulement du pôle santé
oui il ya toujours un pari il ya
toujours un pari mais je pense qu'on est
un bourg dynamique
nos médecins sont jeunes le cas le cas
échéant s'il avait été proche de la
retraite je n'aurais pas hésité à
investir vu le dynamisme du bourg qui
attirera toujours de jeunes médecins de
cette vitalité
monsieur le maire en est fier selon lui
elle vient des aides financières qu'il a
reçus mais pas seulement
la centralité de rougemont
permet comme tous nos commerces se situe
autour d'un parking
je pense que l'accueil et c'est la
commune a réalisé aussi des travaux qui
fait des prêts espaces publics une par
une et je pense que c'est ce qui attire
aussi le monde attire le monde mais pas
autant qu'espéré puisque malgré ses
atouts rougemont ne gagne pas
d'habitants